what's going on guys national master james canty
the third here with chess.com and today we have
game of the day with titled tuesday with the
white pieces we have hikaru nakamura and with the
black pieces we have liam frolick let's get right
into it nakamura plays knight f3 uh very flexible
something like already we don't know what he's
going to play yet so let's see what happens d5
and then here we go flexibility is very important
b3 with the larson system or the nimsovich larson
attack it's a very very strong opening and
actually very underrated guys if you don't know
what to do with the black pieces i've had many
positions where i just didn't know what to do and
i had to study it afterwards so b3 is very very
interesting let's see what happens here bishop
to f5 and then g3 so he's actually going to finn
kettle both of the bishops here which is actually
very nice he controls both of the diagonals here
and just has time to do honestly whatever he wants
we're going to sit back and wait a little bit e6
and then beautiful move here instead of bishops of
g2 or bishop b2 like we would see in these moves
he actually played knight to h4 stating that hey
you locked your bishop outside of the pawn chain
bishops are slightly better than knights all great
masters will tell you this and now with that
being said we're going to capture this bishop
because it's just out here and actually the bishop
pair is always an advantage and if we're able to
take this we're also able to ruin black's pawn
structure as well so knight h4 kind of like in a
london system kind of way with the colors reversed
actually sometimes with black you will see knight
h5 hitting the bishop on f4 trying to take this
bishop in london system fashion so knight h4 then
we have bishop to g4 here trying to provoke a
weakness and he also just wants to back up this
way maybe take towards the file h3 bishop to h5
and instead of g4 he just says bishop b2 let's
stay flexible he didn't he doesn't know what i'm
going to do yet we kind of made some moves he just
threw him off like knight h4 and g3 stuff that
he didn't expect right um right out of the bat
here and bishop to b2 is a good move knight to d7
doing some development here and then d3 just uh
get getting some type of uh stake in the center
here e4 is coming followed by uh of course knight
to d2 maybe first and e4 in a good fashion
especially after we neutralize this attack
right here so knight g to f6 and then we have
g4 there it is on the board guys very aggressive
kind of chess here very aggressive kind of chess
reminds you of a kings indian but with the reverse
colors here and you can't castle to the side of
the board guys you probably should not castle to
this side of the board just because of the the
fact that the pawns are uh loose here and you
push them right in front of the king and they
supposed to be uh saving your king or give you
some safety and shelter while your castle bishop
to g6 and knight to d2 then after bishop to d6 we
have e3 guys and if you ever heard of the hippo
which is usually played with the black pieces
you can also play it with white but it usually
goes like this you put your pawns only on the
third rank it will be the sixth rank for black but
you put your bishops on b2 and g2 the knights go
to d2 and usually e2 this one's a little bit far
out but you kind of the same situation where you
actually just kind of sit back and wait it's more
of a counter punching counter attacking you swing
i duck i swing back i hit kind of thing it happens
all the time a lot of counts are counter-attacking
chances when you play this kind of opening but
you need to know what you're doing do not try
this at home unless you know what you're doing
after e3 queen to e7 and here we go a3 with the
hippopotamus type setup here guys if you see h3 e3
d3 b3 a3 everything's on a third rank besides the
g pawn here and the knight's not on e2 it's on h4
which is a little bit better here because we can't
capture this bishop here and uh just kind of a
flexible position just to see what blacks does
e5 and then bishop to g2 by hikaru and then c6 i'm
just going to say hey this bishop is very strong
we don't want it to be that strong so we're going
to make sure we make this a brick wall in front of
it queen to e2 i'm not saying where we're going
to castle yet most likely queen side if we even
castle let's see what happens castle queen
cy and here we go b4 an aggressive move here
now you guys if you've played if you played the
modern before if you played the hippopotamus
before this is one of the themes where you
actually push this pawn bring the knight over
and launch a king or queen side attack depending
on what's going on on the board here so we may
not even see a castle from icaru let's see what
happens rick hce8 centralizing all of the pieces
guys looks like nothing's wrong here honestly just
a good position kind of can't push forward yet so
we're just trying to figure out what to do but
after rook hd e8 we have c4 from hikaru he says
you know what i'm not even going to castle i'm
just going to go for it he's going to attack the
king here now when you cast him on opposite sides
whoever gets to the king first is going to win
but we're actually not even castled here so we're
just going straight for the king what an all-out
attack here king to b8 just trying to get a little
bit safe here and here comes the reinforcements
we're bringing our friends for the end knight
b3 and then e4 here this is a way to break up
this strong center here or what's going on this
is attacked this is attack if you take this way
i might take this way if you take this way then
i'll take this way so it's kind of a it's a very
strong move to be honest and actually you have to
respond to it somehow so instead of a d take c4
here we go knight takes g6 first get rid of this
monster bishop that was on this diagonal we now
have the bishops here and after knight takes
we have h6 h takes g6 and then c5 attacking
the bishop closing the file and wants to follow
up here guys can you can you name the next move
what would you do in this position as white if you
were karu nakamura what would you do why to move
here we go the move is actually d4 lock it up lock
it up whoever controls the pawn breaks controls
the game and in this point who controls the pawn
break what's a pawn break you ask a pawn break is
actually when you can break up something so look
at this this is a perfect example f3 is one and
b5 is another way to actually break up this now
black doesn't have any well maybe b6 but this
is not realistic and you actually don't want to
do this with this king here more realistically
would be maybe f5 here but definitely nothing
for black white controls the game at the pace
that they wanted to and your pawn structure tells
you where you should play so realistically black
should be playing on the queen side or king side
but it doesn't look like there's a lot there and
white should be playing on the queen side where it
looks like there's a lot there so after d4 there's
g5 on the board and then we have a4 he's going
forward he's trying to crush him let's see if
it works knight to f8 then we have b5 he's opening
up the king side and black is just sitting around
trying to defend and figure out what to do with
life at this point knight to g6 b takes c6 hey
the front door is wide open we are going to bring
our friends right inside queen a6 and knight h4
hitting the bishop here it is attacked so we do
need to do something about it so he just backs
it up bishop to f1 knight f3 this knight made how
many moves guys one two three four moves just to
get a check in we go king d1 and what's your
next move we actually need to use more pieces
remember chess is a team game you can't just
use a knight or any just one piece to try to win
it does happen sometimes but you are playing
half man half everything else see caro nakamura
knight f3 it's going to be extremely hard to
get this knight off of here but you can't you
don't have any attack as black here it's very very
scary here and black is on the defense queen to d7
trying to defend the light squares because knight
h4 will be one all kind of things are going to be
deadly here bishop c3 time to open the file
even put a knight maybe on a5 or bishop on a5
king to a8 and then king to c2 interesting move
here maybe activating the rook also keeping the
the knight defended and even bringing the king
just slightly closer uh okay rook to b8 and then
bishop to e2 he's just trying to develop but
also keep the rooks connected at the same time
rook to b7 we're gonna double on the file
why not and then rook h to b1 here it goes
rook e to b8 and here we go guys can you find
the next move when you look at this kind of
position this position is placed in front of
you what do you do how do you proceed as white
and the move here guys is bishop b5
whoa and that's not even the best part
of today bishop to b5 this is going to get
absolutely crazy at this point the threat is
of course bishop takes c6 how do you defend it
let's look at the options rook b6 that's just
not a move and then 95 that's not a move either
so we only have really one option here which is
actually taking on b5 which he does here c takes
b5 here we go c6 thank you so much i'm going to
win an exchange here if you do nothing else but
he actually plays rook to b6 and he says aha
if you take my queen i take yours white to
move guys what do you do in this position
hikaru nakamura lifted up his mouse and
clicked queen takes a7 oh my goodness wow
bizarre queen sacrifice tal is here today
queen takes a seven king takes a takes b5
rook a6 and rook takes a6 check may have a
nice day hikaru nakamura has done it again here
especially with one of his pet openings the larson
system which you guys can start playing today it's
an unorthodox opening and people don't study as
much so you do have a big advantage there that was
absolutely brilliant here actually right here was
the stunning moment bishop to b5 such a hard move
to find and then the follow-up here the follow-up
is even the hardest c6 rook b6 and you're like oh
what do i do you look for the forcing moves
first checks and captures queen takes a7
takes takes and check mate have a good day wow
that was awesome here man what a game and what an
exciting uh analysis here today as well guys thank
you so much for watching i'm national master james
canton iii here with chess.com and this was game
of the day and i'll see you guys on the next video